Another 48 people in my Godmother's
house okay and I would go up there on
like the weekends and there was a model
place when I came from Cuba I didn't
speak good English so I was ashamed to
talk okay so I would just get [__]
models and build stupid [__] models
of ships and Superman yeah and every day
I would go down to that model place and
it was always a skinny guy outside you
know like hey hey kidding you're gonna
go inside can you get me a tube of glue
and one day the dude said it to me he
goes don't get that [__] guy glue he
snorts it and I'm like snort it I don't
even know what the [__] you're talking
about I'm like five or six I don't hablo
son I fought him one day we were taking
out my my godmother owned three
buildings on 148th Street and Broadway
and I was helping to take the trash out
and I caught him and behind the garbage
can Huff often but when I go his name
was Charlie I go Charlie he went like
this the bag stuck to his hand he
couldn't get rid of the bag because the
glue had been on his hand so we started
calling them sticky Charlie so I figured
he would get a check from the government
every month because he got hit in the
head with like a missile in Vietnam yeah
so then
this [__] would go to a glue
place and buy a case of it yeah and then
spend all the money I still remember it
was he lived like on 148 between like
Broadway and Amsterdam yeah and we would
walk to his house and he'd be having
glue parties in the basement with a
bunch of glue holes
with glue hose right
so I went to my mom one day and I'm he
had a hard time buying glue
he would always have a hard time let's
say the glue was 25 cents in those okay
just a tube yeah nobody would sell them
glue so I told my mom
let me borrow 20. I'm gonna buy a case
of glue and pimp this [__] out so
that's your first mark That's My First
Mark I started hitting how old are you
you're five years old Charlie six seven
I'm selling glue to Sticky [__]
Charlie and I'm hanging out I'm living
on 88th Street yeah right there right 88
and Broadway okay yes I lived on 205
West 88th Street and I went to PS 166.
and [__] that neighborhood was okay
yeah like they were like white kids that
were okay you know yeah like I had like
a Chinese girlfriend her father worked
for Schultz you know the dude who
[__] drawers
she was a Chinese so we would go to
movie theaters and they closed the
movies in New York City another guy in
my building was the producer of
beetlemania so he went to see
beetlemania's kids like a rehearsal it
was a great neighborhood but 148th
Street was a way better [__] thing
yeah they had Puerto Rican kids yeah it
was Irish kids yeah the Jewish kids and
they were all dirty yeah
nobody was clean in fact I used to dress
down when I went up there yeah because I
didn't want them feeling bad I'm a West
Side kid yeah I got my own air
conditioner in my room these guys
eliminate to a room yeah with a [__]
fan on with sheets on at night so I
would dress down I would put holes in my
pants I would put like money in my back
but these kids were Hustlers they were
already shaking down the neighborhood
really like they had like two blocks
that they would go into and say listen
we want to take your garbage out clean
the window sweet no we break the [__]
Windows these kids were already young
and they were anywhere from six to ten
so so okay real quick back up you've got
your first Mark is your mother proud my
mom don't [__] know
thought you're like yo give me 20 bucks
today to buy glue for models
so where do you get in your head like I
can take advantage of this situation
like because he's [__] [__] up
would she be upset or you think she'd be
like okay she would have giggled the
body yeah what the [__] are you doing
you can't be selling glue yeah but but
you talk about no childhood no
six-year-old is gonna see a business
opportunity at six years old yeah that's
a grown ass thing no child today yeah
okay a good day my daughter got in the
car after kickboxing and she goes do you
have an uh
do I have an Uncle Julio
and I go yeah you got an Uncle Julio
Julio Rodriguez and she goes what did I
meet him and I go you met him when you
were like four up north he owns a jiu
jitsu School in North Bergen okay
remember we went up there she's like oh
yeah yeah I go how is he your cousin I
go well our parents were bookies yeah
and me Julio and his brother guilla who
they used to call sandwich because he
was a fat kid like when we were eight
they just call him Sam they just gave up
I was like okay your name is sandwich
and I I said you know what I'll let you
know and I just called Julio and I go
talk to him I go Julio tell her what we
used to do on Saturdays when we were
kids
and Julio's told them we'd go to the
Bronx
we were like eight we go to the Bronx
and run numbers and they pay us 50 bucks
for the day
and we'll be on the street corners just
taking numbers from people with a
[__] adult watching us three four
kids and then we'd have to run errands
go get coffee cigarettes but that's what
we did 50 day back that is crazy money
what's happening even now you know how
many [__] Bruce Lee movies how much
glue you can buy yeah you're living who
was doing security when like who was
collecting the money for your for your
mom and the other girl if you know the
guys didn't want to pay up no they
always pay us like a dollar you know
like 215 for a dollar 310 for two
dollars the biggest bet you had was like
maybe five dollars no so there's nobody
they had to worry about not paying no
because it was all Community it was a
neighborhood watch you guys you know
what you're gonna beat me for five
you're gonna get a beating in those days
for the five dollars and I'm like now in
those days five dollars you got kicked
or something somebody threw a bottle or
something yeah and then you couldn't put
any more bets in so it was simpler oh
yeah you were [__] you still want to
be part of this community you want to be
part that's part
Bronx in Brooklyn those with that's what
keeps those people alive but who would
your mother go to to give the beatings
or would she give the beatings herself
what do you mean like like somebody
didn't want it nobody really like in my
world gave you a beat but that was
bookmakers that did give you a [__]
yeah you know yeah like to fight out
whatever it was like they'd smack you
you know yeah [__] like that nonsense